her children and her mother so they ran
to the woods from their Village in
nagorno-karabakh as azerbaijan's
military Advanced on the region
they've not been home since and walked
here from the border
Susanna's eldest son Eric says what
they're wearing is all they were able to
bring with them
watch me now we have nothing we lift
everything there we just left our homes
on September 19th at midday because of
the war we'd been told we had to leave
because the enemy was approaching and no
one stayed in the village now we're in
this situation
as Armenia tries to accommodate all
those who fled many are coming to terms
with the destruction of a project that
began in 1988 that was when the
Armenians of karabakh first tried to
break away from Soviet Azerbaijan
we don't know where we will sleep
tonight
I just can't imagine the future my
thoughts are mixed now I don't know what
we will do at all I blame Azerbaijan
they captured our land and forced us out
from our Village from our motherland and
now we're like this many of those here
say they feared ethnic cleansing if they
stayed in karabakh claims dismissed as
nonsense by Azerbaijan
azerbaijan's capture of nagorno-karabakh
has triggered one of the biggest
movements of people in this region since
the fall of the Soviet Union the
government in Baku has repeatedly said
it guarantees the security of ethnic
Armenians who prefer to stay put but
there's no one here willing to take up
that offer
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera goris Armenia
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera